The upcoming Game of Thrones prequel series,
House of the Dragon, is based on the George
RR Martin's Targaryen history book Fire & Blood.
House of the Dragon is a Game of Thrones prequel
show that is confirmed by HBO’s president
to air in 2022.
Miguel Sapochnik and Ryan Condal will serve
as showrunners and executive producers. George
R. R. Martin will also serve as executive
producer.
It is based on George RR Martin’s book Fire
And Blood volume 1 and on Martin’s yet unfinished
Fire And Blood volume 2 book.
“Fire & Blood begins their tale with the
legendary Aegon the Conqueror, creator of
the Iron Throne, and goes on to recount the
generations of Targaryens who fought to hold
that iconic seat, all the way up to the civil
war that nearly tore their dynasty apart.”
In other words, it covers events from Aegon's
Conquest to the Dance of the Dragons.
That's Fire And Blood volume 1.
The yet unreleased Fire And Blood volume 2
will continue from where part 1 ended, with
Rhaenyra Targaryen's son Aegon lll's reign
and will cover Blackyre rebellions, war with
Dorne and go all the way to the Mad King and
Robert's Rebellion that ended Targaryen dynasty.
But back to Aegon's Conquest.
As Arya Stark reminded Tywin Lannister in
season 2 of Game of Thrones,
Aegon was not the only one riding a dragon
during his Conquest.
''It wasn't just Aegon riding his dragon,
it was Rhaenys and Visenya, too...
Rhaenys rode Meraxes, Visenya rode Vhagar...
Visenya Targaryen was a great warrior.
She had a Valyrian steel sword she called
'Dark Sister'."
Arya also revealed to Tywin that Visenya was
a heroine of hers.
Queen Visenya Targaryen was the older sister
and wife of Aegon the Conqueror,
the first Lord of the Seven Kingdoms. Her
younger sister, Rhaenys, was married to Aegon
as well. Visenya was a dragonrider, and rode
the dragon Vhagar.
Like her siblings, Visenya possessed the classical
Valyrian features: long, silver-gold hair,
which she often braided or bound up in rings,
and purple eyes.
Hers was a harsher beauty than her sister,
Rhaenys. Sensual and passionate woman,
Visenya was also stern, serious, and unforgiving.
Some claimed that Visenya dabbled in dark
sorceries and played with poisons.
Visenya was both a dragonrider and a warrior,
comfortable in both silk and in ringmail.
When garbed as a warrior, she always wielded
the Valyrian steel longsword Dark Sister.
Visenya was the mother of infamous Maegor
Targaryen, known as Maegor the Cruel,
the third King of the Seven Kingdoms, but
he died without issue,
so all of the subsequent Targaryen rulers
(including Daenerys Targaryen)
claim their descent from Visenya's sister,
Rhaenys. But let's start from the very beginning.
Born on the island Dragonstone, Visenya was
the eldest child of Lord Aerion Targaryen
and Lady Valaena Velaryon. Her two younger
siblings, Aegon and Rhaenys, were born within
a few years following her birth. Since young
age, Visenya trained together with Aegon at
arms,
and she became a skilled warrior. As expected,
Visenya was wed to her brother Aegon
following Valyrian custom. However, Aegon
took their younger sister as a wife as well.
People claimed that he had wed Visenya out
of duty, and Rhaenys out of desire.
Prior to her wedding, Visenya became a dragonrider,
having bonded with the dragon Vhagar.
When Aegon's Conquest of the Seven Kingdoms
began, Visenya sailed with her siblings from
Dragonstone. While Aegon began construction
of the Aegonfort, Visenya subdued House Stokeworth
by setting ablaze the roofs of Stokeworth.
After the defeat of House Darklyn in Aegon's
first test,
Visenya claimed the riches of Duskendale,
swelling the coffers of House Targaryen.
Having conquered a dozen houses and secured
the mouth of the Blackwater,
Aegon was crowned king at the Aegonfort. Visenya,
now a queen,
placed a Valyrian steel circlet on Aegon's
head
while their sister Rhaenys hailed him as the
new King of All Westeros.
Following the coronation, Visenya accompanied
the Targaryen fleet to Gulltown and the Vale
of Arryn. When the Arryn fleet sunk a third
of Targaryen ships and captured many more
in a battle in the waters off Gulltown, Visenya
descended from the sky upon Vhagar, burning
their ships.
Next, Visenya was sent to Crackclaw Point
by Aegon.
The local lords had learned of the death of
Harren Hoare,
King of the Isles and the Rivers, at the burning
of Harrenhal by Aegon,
so the Crackclaws submitted quickly to Visenya,
swearing oaths of fealty.
Visenya took them as her own men,
and from that day forth the lords owed their
loyalty directly to the Iron Throne.
Visenya met Rhaenys, Aegon, and the Targaryen
host at Stoney Sept, from where they raced
south. There, they met the combined hosts
of the Reach and the westerlands in battle.
Visenya and her siblings fought from dragonback,
setting dry grasses and stands of wheat on
the battlefield afire.
With more than four thousand men dead from
the fire, and tens of thousands wounded by
the flames, the battle became known as the
Field of Fire. Mern IX Gardener, King of the
Reach,
died in battle while Loren I Lannister, King
of the Rock fled and bent the knee,
giving Targaryens the victory. According to
legend,
Visenya thanked the gods that Loren had ridden
forth to face the Targaryens
when she saw Casterly Rock, as she believed
that dragon flame would not have been able
to dishearten the Lannister king if he had
remained inside the Rock.
Visenya had taken an arrow in the shoulder
during the Field of Fire, but soon recovered.
Following the surrender of King Loren, the
three Targaryen siblings parted ways once
more,
but met soon again at the banks of the Trident,
where they awaited the host of Torrhen Stark,
King in the North. After Torrhen bent the
knee, Visenya parted from her siblings and
returned to the Vale, where House Arryn had
strengthened their defenses.
A strong host had been positioned at the Bloody
Gate.
However, Visenya bypassed these hosts by flying
up to the Eyrie upon Vhagar's back.
She landed in the courtyard, where she was
met by Ronnel Arryn,
the young King of Mountain and Vale.
Ronnel's regent and mother, Lady Sharra Arryn,
surrendered the Eyrie to Visenya.
Visenya fought alongside her siblings in the
First Dornish War,
which lasted from 4 AC to 13 AC. After Rhaenys
died in Dorne in 10 AC, Visenya and Aegon,
grief-stricken at her death, set every castle,
keep, and holdfast in Dorne ablaze at least
once,
with the exception of Sunspear.
They also placed bounties on the heads of
the Dornish lords.
Although half a dozen and more of those lords
were killed by assassins,
only two of the killers lived to collect their
reward.
In retaliation, the Dornish lords hired catspaws
themselves.
Visenya and her escort were once attacked
in King's Landing,
and she cut the last would-be assassin down
herself with Dark Sister.
Visenya also single-handedly saved her brother,
husband and king Aegon from assassins.
When the Conqueror argued that his guards
were still sufficient for his protection,
Visenya drew Dark Sister. Before his guards
could react, she had cut Aegon's cheek,
pointing out to him that his guards were slow
and lazy. This event led to the birth of the
Kingsguard. Visenya modeled the vows of the
Kingsguard upon the vows of the Night's Watch,
and she selected the first seven members herself.
Rhaenys's death in Dorne in 10 AC shattered
the health of her son Aenys,
and people began to doubt as to whether he
would live.
As Visenya had not yet gotten pregnant by
Aegon despite more than a decade of marriage,
some had come to believe that she was barren,
and even went as far as to suggest to Aegon
that he should take a new wife. Although many
young women were presented to Aegon,
he refused to voice his opinion on the matter.
In 11 AC, Visenya announced she was pregnant
with a son, and the next year, she gave birth
to Aegon's second son, Maegor on Dragonstone.
Visenya raised Maegor on Dragonstone, and
gave him her Valyrian steel sword, Dark Sister,
as a nameday present when the boy turned thirteen.
In 23 AC, Aenys's first child, Princess Rhaena,
was born. Shortly after Maegor turned twelve,
Visenya proposed a betrothal between her son
Maegor and Rhaena, to settle the issue of
the royal succession, as Rhaena's birth had
sparked discussion about who was next in line
behind Aenys:
his own daughter, or his brother. However,
this never happened.
Visenya's relationship with Aegon, which had
never been a warm one, grew more distant.
When Aegon in 35 AC had the Aegonfort torn
down so they could start building the Red
Keep,
Visenya was left in charge of the construction.
In his histories, Archmaester Gyldayn states
that it was suggested at court that Aegon
had left Visenya at King's Landing so that
he would not have to endure her presence on
Dragonstone.
When Aegon died, both Visenya and Maegor were
present
as his body was cremated and Aenys I Targaryen
was crowned.
Aenys gifted Maegor with Blackfyre saying
he was more fit to wield it.
Visenya Targaryen voiced the opinion that
Aenys was unfit to rule,
claiming that, by giving Blackfyre to Maegor,
Aenys had admitted that he lacked the strength
to rule.
In 39 AC, Visenya's son Maegor shocked the
realm by taking a second wife and married
Alys Harroway. The outrage that followed resulted
in Maegor being sent into exile.
Visenya was present the next year at the wedding
of King Aenys' children Princess Rhaena to
Prince Aegon. At the feast that followed the
ceremony, King Aenys named Aegon Prince of
Dragonstone,
the title which had previously belonged to
Maegor. Visenya left the feast in protest
and returned to Dragonstone upon Vhagar. Singers
claim that the moon turned red as they passed
it.
Rhaenys died in Dorne before the end of Aegon's
reign,
and a few years after Aegon's death their
bastard half-brother Orys died
after an attempted conquest of Dorne,
meaning that Visenya was the last surviving
member of the Conquest-generation of Targaryens.
She continued to exert political influence
during the reign of Aegon's successor,
Rhaenys's son Aenys I - who proved to be a
weakling,
and was totally overwhelmed when the Faith
Militant uprising broke out,
and fled from King's Landing to Dragonstone.
The stress of the uprisings caused Aenys to
fall gravely ill,
and Visenya was called in to try to heal him
with her arcane knowledge of potions.
For a time, Aenys actually seemed to recover,
but when news came that his son and daughter
were besieged at Crakehall, his health drastically
worsened again.
Some suspect that Visenya poisoned her nephew,
although others point out that he did seem
to be recovering.
Even those who suspect she killed him debate
her motivations:
some think it was a cynical power-grab for
her son Maegor,
while others think she did it for the good
of the Targaryen dynasty,
as Aenys had proved to be a failure and incapable
of resisting the Faith Militant.
Within hours of Aenys's death, Visenya flew
to Pentos to retrieve Maegor from exile.
They returned with Vhagar, Maegor riding his
father's dragon Balerion,
and an army of several hundred sellswords.
Maegor then proclaimed himself a king ahead
of Aenys's surviving sons and daughters,
usurping the throne, and proceeded to reclaim
King's Landing.
Visenya accompanied him to King's Landing,
where she challenged anyone who denied Maegor's
right to rule, which resulted in a trial of
seven between Maegor and the Warrior's Sons.
Although severely injured, Maegor was the
only survivor.
Visenya ultimately died late in Maegor the
Cruel's reign from a sudden illness.
Maegor lost a key ally, and Vhagar was left
riderless.
Not long afterward all the Great Houses finally
turned against Maegor openly,
and he died on the Iron Throne itself. Visenya
was cremated as per Targaryen custom.
Her bones and ashes were interred beside those
of her brother-husband, King Aegon I Targaryen.
That's the story of Queen Visenya Targaryen,
the warrior sister and wife of Aegon the Conqueror
with whom she had a son Maegor the Cruel.
Along with her siblings, Visenya played a
key role in the Targaryen invasion of Westeros,
her most notable action being the single-handed
conquest of the Vale of Arryn.
Thank you so much for watching, I hope you
enjoyed this video and if you did please give
it a big thumbs up and I hope to see you in
the next one. Peace!